[Music]
on this thursday night big changes to
military misconduct investigations
the military will no longer be able to
police and investigate itself that is a
bold and major move the new defense
minister's plan to rebuild trust in the
canadian armed forces
cancer confirmed bc premier john
horgan's diagnosis and his message to
the public
warding cyber threats we haven't stood
up to this one strategy to fight hackers
after that attack on newfoundland and
labrador's health care system
and meanwhile in saskatoon the moose
that hoofed it to school
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
[Music]
good evening and thanks for joining us
just 10 days into her new job and
canada's new defense minister sent a big
signal today on how she intends to
handle sexual misconduct cases that have
festered and gone unpunished in the
canadian forces for years anita anand
has agreed allegations including those
against the top brass should be handled
by the civilian system she's accepted
the recommendations of louise arbor a
retired supreme court justice tasked
with coming up with ways to end the
persistent problem arbor says recurrent
allegations of historical sexual
misconduct against senior canadian
forces leaders means immediate remedial
actions are necessary to start restoring
trust in the canadian armed forces she
recommends all allegations should be
referred to civilian authorities and
charges should be laid in a civilian
court abigail beeman breaks down arbor's
recommendations and when they could be
implemented in our top story tonight
in issuing her call for immediate change
louise arbor said she heard significant
skepticism with respect to the
independence and competence of the cfnis
and military police and that has created
serious mistrust in the military justice
system
and the new minister of defense who
tweeted this singular image on day one
of the job flanked by all women at
defense headquarters is ready for change
that is a bold and major move that we
are making today she met with arbor
monday and anita anand says she will
work to implement our boar's interim
recommendations immediately we have to
ensure that we are implementing durable
and long-lasting reforms
and so
what is occurring right now is the
consultation
between the pro-belles marshal and the
director of military prosecutions with
their provincial and territorial
counterparts i've been arguing it for
the past 20 years so i couldn't be more
pleased military lawyer michelle drapeau
calls this a game changer that will see
military victims treated equally if we
were looking for one as to how do we
get out of this mess
and how do we reestablish control and
send a powerful signal to victims
uh would-be assaulters
and the military justice system is
basically to do this what happens with
this change is that you remove the
serious conflict of interest that is
in place in the military three days
before our boar sent her letter global
news reported a senior naval officer
witnessed an alleged 2010 assault on
naval lieutenant heather mcdonald by
admiral art mcdonald and says he told
police no charges were laid i certainly
think that the difference between the
military
prosecutors and civilian prosecutors
would have changed the outcome of the
case yes on and couldn't say how quickly
transfers will happen there is precedent
the civilian system handled cases like
these until 1998. some military watchers
are concerned past problems could be
repeated we need to find out how the
department of national defense and the
relevant
law enforcement authorities are going to
implement this to avoid the mistakes
that we have seen in the 1990s being
repeated justice arbor's letter is dated
october 20th addressed to then minister
harjit sajin arbor asked for it to be
made public we asked new minister anand
why it took more than two weeks to do so
she said she learned of the letter after
she was sworn in and feels she's moved
expeditiously donna all right abigail
beeman in ottawa thanks the military is
also making changes it says will help
make the canadian armed forces more safe
welcoming and inclusive the acting chief
of the military personnel says there
will be a new dress code to remove
separate rules for men and women the
military is also reviewing its rank
titles in french which are all masculine
and it plans to develop a more rigorous
process for promoting and selecting
leaders within the forces
there's some backlash to the decision by
ontario and quebec not to make covid19
vaccines mandatory for healthcare
workers both provinces say following
through would mean unvaccinated
employees would be suspended and the
resulting labor shortage would
jeopardize the delivery of care that is
not how many medical experts see it eric
sorenson explains
hall in bloorview a children's hospital
in toronto implemented a vaccine mandate
for its health care workers almost two
months ago staff vaccines jumped from 86
to 99 percent and that's made everyone
safer i've got a thousand members of my
team here
every single one
feels safer because they know that their
colleagues are vaccinated but the
ontario government decided it will not
mandate vaccines for health care workers
because it would reduce staffing levels
and services at some hospitals there
were some individual hospitals that did
indicate to us that they were very
concerned about
loss of health human resources yes the
government won't say how many hospitals
don't want mandatory vaccines the
ontario hospital association says in its
survey 120 out of 140 explicitly support
a mandatory regime it's a question of
patient safety and the safety of the
hundreds of thousands of people who work
in ontario's hospitals and across the
water healthcare system six provinces
require mandatory vaccines for
healthcare workers now or very soon four
provinces require tests but not
necessarily vaccines for health workers
and those provinces represent 65 percent
of canada's population british columbia
put more than 3 000 unvaccinated health
workers on unpaid leave but insists a
vaccine requirement is overall better
for health outcomes what we know
that this order is necessary and
important and has made our health care
system safer for everybody hall in
bloorview says two months with a vaccine
mandate has unquestionably worked out
for the best at holland bloorview having
a mandatory vaccination policy has not
impacted our ability to care for our
patients at all and our view was exactly
the opposite that anything short of full
vaccination of our team was more likely
to put
to put our patients at risk one worry is
that unvaccinated health workers will
shop around for places to work the
ontario government says it will monitor
for any upturn in covid cases harder to
measure will be the level of confidence
patients and staff have in institutions
without a mandate eric sorensen global
news toronto
the uk has become the first country in
the world to authorize the use of an
anti-viral pill to treat covit 19. molnu
piravir was developed by american drug
maker merck it's for adults with mild to
moderate cases who are at higher risk of
complications it can be taken at home
twice a day for five days a clinical
trial showed it reduced by half the risk
of hospitalization and death in high
risk covered patients who were treated
early in their infections the pill is
still under review in canada and the u.s
a new report is shedding light on
canada's enormous health care costs
during the pandemic the data from the
canadian institute for health
information says canada will likely
spend more than 300 billion dollars on
health care this year that works out to
more than eight thousand dollars per
canadian the report says it is the
single biggest increase in health
spending ever in canada in 2019 before
the pandemic canada spent about 267
billion on health care
in newfoundland and labrador pressures
of the pandemic are being made worse by
a crippling cyber attack on that
province's health care system the attack
last saturday has caused thousands of
appointments to be canceled and though
parts of the system are back online
today the crisis is not over ross lord
reports on what happened and why the
rest of the country should pay attention
the cyber attack left a health care
system that was already overwhelmed with
another obstacle to overcome i'm
supposed to have an appointment on
monday but that will go ahead now
the attack has disabled newfoundland and
labrador's health data center leading to
the cancellation of thousands of medical
appointments and interrupted critical
services like chemotherapy ed power
fears his son's ongoing hospital
treatments will suffer well i'm a bit
worried
about the you know the kinds of care
that he will get under the circumstances
you know cyber security analysts suspect
it's a ransomware attack in which
hackers render computer files useless
until their victims pay a specified
amount of money i and many other experts
across this country have been loudly
warning the federal government that
every health care system across the
country was under siege and it ramped up
dramatically as the pandemic gained
steam
and the federal government has let this
issue slip through the cracks
the government's lead agency for i.t
security suggests there's no surprise
in a statement the community security
establishment said over the last two
years the number of cyber threat actors
is rising the statement said we continue
to publish advice and guidance to help
organizations be less vulnerable
david shipley says canada needs to
confront cyber criminals even if it
means attacking their computer systems
that's the offense we have to go on
and it's important that we send that
message and we haven't and i think we've
made ourselves a bigger target because
we haven't stood up to this
the newfoundland and labrador government
suggests the worst is over without
explaining how we're listening to
world-class experts as we move through
this cyber attack
speaker and i can say that progress is
being made in our health care system the
government says it's unclear if personal
medical information has been stolen and
when a crisis that's added insult to
injury in health care will be over
also unclear is which province's health
care system will be next to fall victim
to this escalating threat
ross lord global news
bc's premier is thanking the public for
support after announcing he has cancer
john horgan says a biopsy on a growth in
his throat confirmed it was malignant he
says he'll begin radiation treatment in
the coming weeks with me from victoria's
global's keith baldry keith the
premier's being quite forthcoming about
the details about his diagnosis it's not
the first time he's had cancer what more
do we know
yeah he fought successfully bladder
cancer back in 2008 donna and again john
horgan remains very optimistic and
upbeat put out a short statement today
uh saying in part and here's just part
of the the statement from the premier's
office the pathology confirmed that the
growth in my story was cancerous my
prognosis is good and i expect to make a
full recovery in the next couple of
weeks i will need to start radiation
treatment which will conclude toward the
end of december he went on to say he
intends to continue to share cabinet
meetings he's going to continue to chair
the council of the federation which is
the group of premiers across the country
and receive briefings on assorted topics
so it's basically a situation normal as
far as he's concerned when it comes to
work he's just not going to be attending
in-person cabinet meetings and other
meetings and he'll send mike farner with
the deputy premier in his place if he
needs to but it's still very much
hands-on premier from john horgan okay
keith he chose to go public with the
fact he was having a biopsy you know he
didn't have to tell people that why did
he decide not to keep it private
well he joked at first that he went
public because victoria's a small town
and it wouldn't take long for word to
get out that the premier scene in the
hospital but he also said it was an
opportunity to remind people that if you
spot something unusual in your in your
health system your personal health
situation go get treated check it out
don't ignore lumps and such he felt a
lump in his neck he got it checked out
it took a while but they finally got the
biopsy done and the results coming back
and now he expects to make a full
recovery so it was a message to everyone
to again go get checked out don't ignore
the warning signs because early
detection works best in situations such
as this all right keith baldry in
victoria thank you
at cop 26 in glasgow canada is
committing to stop public funding of
overseas fossil fuel projects by the end
of next year canada and the us are among
at least 20 countries that have agreed
to end the financing of fossil fuel
projects abroad it's claimed that would
divert 22 billion dollars a year to
clean energy quitting coal the most
polluting fossil fuel is also a major
topic at the climate summit but in both
cases a few major players are not
signing on crystal gomansing has more
from glasgow
coal is the primary energy supply for
ukraine yet the country is one of the
newest members of the powering pass coal
alliance announced in glasgow several
banks also joined the group dedicated to
phasing out coal so has export
development canada the first agency of
its kind to get on board we started with
being concerned with the question of how
do we put the an end to coal before coal
puts an end to our planet the burning of
coal is the greatest contributor to
climate change and transitioning away
from coal was seen as the greatest step
towards countries achieving the goal of
keeping global warming to 1.5 degrees
major coal users and producers like
china india and the u.s are not signing
on but they have made other commitments
to reduce their reliance on the fossil
fuel the u.s and china pledged to stop
funding coal projects abroad
and at cop 26 india's prime minister
promised to get half of his country's
power from renewables by 2030. advocates
say success at cop is not about one
announcement or one project the bigger
picture must be kept in view we need to
keep calling these countries to do it
fast but it needs to be managed and we
also need to think about workers and
their families and i do see momentum i
see a momentum when it comes to fossil
fuels i do believe we're getting to a
point where we can sign coal power to
history every g7 nation has committed to
ending international coal financing this
year that's fueled cautious optimism
here that the end of coal
may be in sight
crystal gomanson global news glasgow
the pleas for peace in ethiopia coming
up the crisis in the african country and
what is prime minister is urging people
to do plus new details in a child
abduction case in australia and
wild entrance the moose giving new
meaning to crash course
there are growing calls for calm in
ethiopia as that country marks one year
since the start of its bloody civil war
a special envoy from the u.s arrived in
the country's capital urging the
government to begin peace talks the
conflict began a year ago in the
northern tigre region and has resulted
in the deaths of thousands of people and
more than a million have been displaced
from their homes rebels from the north
are now reportedly advancing on the
capitol the prime minister has called on
ethiopians to pick up arms and defend
the city a national state of emergency
is in effect the u.n and the president
of neighboring kenya are appealing for
an immediate end to the fighting
in germany there has been a big spike in
covid19 cases the country reported
nearly 34 000 new infections today that
is the highest daily number since the
start of the pandemic the german health
minister is calling it a massive
pandemic of the unvaccinated about 66
percent of the population in germany is
fully vaccinated covid icu admissions
are also at their highest point since
june
an australian man has been charged with
the abduction of a four-year-old girl
who vanished from her family's campsite
police say they found four-year-old cleo
smith safe and well inside a locked
house yesterday she had disappeared from
her family's tent nearly three weeks ago
a 36-year-old man has been charged with
various offenses including forcibly
taking a child under 16. police say they
believe he acted alone the girl is now
home with her parents is said to be
adjusting well and getting lots of
cuddles
benefit backfire ahead why pandemic 8 is
now draining the wallets of seniors
you're watching global national
[Music]
many canadians have been sustained by
government support payments during the
pandemic not only are they key to
supporting livelihoods they also protect
the most vulnerable citizens among them
low-income seniors many were already
relying on financial aid before the
pandemic hit and as david aiken reports
some of them are now finding they've
been stripped of the payments they
depended on
as she turned 65 last spring luanne
bannister was thrilled to be able to
rent this home in downtown edmonton and
when i found this place it was within my
budget and it's turned out to be a
fabulous
neighborhood but her budget included
receiving her monthly guaranteed income
supplement or gis from the federal
government but then as she moved in
during the summer disaster i get a
notice from the government telling me
that my gis has been
depleted
so that was panic city banister is one
of tens of thousands of seniors whose
gis was cut off or reduced because the
pandemic benefits they received in 2020
like the serb pushed them temporarily
into a higher income bracket making them
appear as if they were no longer
low-income seniors but of course they
still are low-income seniors and they
count on that gis check which could be
as much as 950 dollars a month
without that check
the heat is so low it's
freezing to death
and i have to plan how many trips i make
when i'm driving
groceries are now a gourmet meals craft
dinner it has a devastating effect to
force them into extreme poverty often
with no other means or
avenue of support
seniors say there was no warning from
ottawa that receiving pandemic benefits
might jeopardize gis payments across the
board they're always surprised they had
absolutely no idea
new democrats plan to make this issue a
top priority in parliament we're going
to keep pushing until the government
recognizes that what it's doing to our
most vulnerable seniors right now
is simply unacceptable and that they
need to change course
and if there is no change of course it's
to the point where i just
don't know how i'm going to survive
the new minister of seniors carmel caro
was not available for an interview but
her office said in a statement that
seniors who have had their gis taken
away can apply to have some of it
reinstated for limited circumstances and
those requests will be considered on a
case-by-case basis
david aiken global news ottawa
up next a spectacular display of
nature's greatest light show
talk about a crash course this moose
smashed its way into a classroom in
saskatoon it had been spotted wandering
outside and then ran through a plate
glass window of an elementary school one
student was hurt but didn't need medical
attention and neither did the moose it
was tranquilized by conservation
officers and released
outside the city
and nature treated parts of the country
to one of the most intense displays of
northern lights in years auroras danced
across the skies in an astonishing
multitude of colors and were captured by
photographers in a number of places a
u.s satellite also took some out of this
world shots of the northern lights
streaking over north america the
intensity was caused by a solar flare
which sent blasts of plasma from the sun
unleashing a major geomagnetic storm
just stunning and that is global
national for this thursday i'm donna
friesen we leave you tonight with the
festival of lights millions of people
are celebrating diwali signifying peace
and joy and marking the victory of light
over darkness it's celebrated all over
the world by various religions and
cultures especially in south asia
tonight we leave you with celebrations
in surrey british columbia
thanks for watching robin gill will be
at the anchor desk tomorrow and i will
see you on saturday for the new reality
take care of yourselves bye-bye
[Music]
you